this episode of legal eagle was made
possible by skill share learn to think
like a lawyer for free for two months by
clicking the link in the description ah
PewDiePie PewDiePie love him or hate him
there is no denying he is one of the
most influential people in the online
world today the Swede whose real name is
Felix Felix
whose real name is Felix has over 96
million subscribers at the time of this
video that is an astonishing number for
a guy who got his start just making
funny videos for gamers like others who
accidentally built an enormous online
platform PewDiePie has a way of
stumbling into controversy his most
recent controversy involves India's High
Court blocking two of his YouTube videos
that were allegedly defamatory racist
and offensive what the heck is
defamation in India and how is it
different in the United States well
that's the topic of today's video
[Music]
hey legal eagles it's time to think like
a lawyer PewDiePie has built an
incredibly large media company just by
being a version of himself the Swede is
known for juvenile jokes meme reviews
pop culture commentary video gaming and
goofy music videos
there's of course an enormous appetite
for this kind of content and it has paid
off handsomely for PewDiePie whose net
worth is over 20 million dollars
pewdiepie the youtuber thrives on
arguments and seems to get a kick out of
provoking people and of course this is
going to rub some people the wrong way
over the last three years a handful of
loosely affiliated far-right groups have
seized on some of pewdiepies comments
some people think that PewDiePie
welcomes this association but others
think that his comments are taken out of
context and blown way out of proportion
a few of the controversy swirling around
PewDiePie include him once saying the
n-word while playing a video game making
nine videos in six months that include
references to Nazis including swastikas
Nazi salutes and photos of Hitler he
included the video clip of a person
dressed as Jesus saying Hitler did
absolutely nothing wrong those videos
caused Disney to back out of a contract
with PewDiePie to produce original
content and he used a freelancing
website Fiverr to hire two Indian men to
hold up a banner reading death to all
Jews through Dahl PewDiePie has
maintained that these were just juvenile
jokes gone wrong and has admitted to his
mistakes in the past I'm really sorry if
I offended her or disappointed anyone
with all of this unfortunately some
right-wing communities have adopted
PewDiePie as a kind of mascot in their
movement posting about him in a neo-nazi
site at the Daily stormer and making
lots of memes promoting his content
these kind of third-party attributions
reached a fever pitch after the New
Zealand Mosque Massacre when the shooter
actually encouraged people to quote
subscribed to PewDiePie as was part of
the internet name at the time I think
it's time to end that subscribe to
PewDiePie movement or mean PewDiePie
staunchly maintains that he is not a
supporter of any right-wing causes but
others have said that pápai has not done
enough to distance himself from these
various groups generally PewDiePie has
reiterated that
overall stance is it's just a joke and
it's all a parody which takes us to
t-series the latest issue involving
PewDiePie's sense of humor involves the
Indian record company t-series which has
a huge following on YouTube in its own
right as of the time of this video the
Indian record label t-series has the
biggest YouTube channel in the entire
world which recently surpassed
PewDiePie's channel with over 97 million
subscribers and Counting it looks like
t-series is going to be the first
channel to reach a hundred million
subscribers in the entire world
after t-series surpassed PewDiePie and
followers he responded with two
satirical diss tracks one called
congratulations and the other called
lasagne we are definitely going to have
to bleep out lasagna because lasagna is
totally inappropriate t-series was not
amused by the two videos the company
filed a lawsuit in Indian Court alleging
that the videos were disparaging
defamatory racist and offensive back in
October of 2018 PewDiePie apologised for
the tracks in his typical fashion
claiming that it was just a joke and
removed the tracks for a while when the
tracks remained on the channel t-series
filed for an injunction in the Indian
legal system to get the videos taken
down so what did PewDiePie say to get
into trouble well the track
congratulations is a tongue-in-cheek
music video that purports to
congratulate t-series on surpassing
PewDiePie's channel in number of
subscribers but here's what the song
actually says PewDiePie accuses them of
once being a purveyor of pirated songs
and videos
he says the t-series sent him a
defamation letter he insinuates that
they have ties to the Indian mafia he
asserts that he has never defamed them
and that his opinion isn't defamation
saying for legal reasons that's a joke
popular youtuber boy in a band who
co-wrote the song goes into great detail
about the songwriting process hi I'm
Dave from boyinaband and recently me and
my friend roomie had made a song with
PewDiePie
whoa whoa whoa calm down fellas it's
definitely worth a look on his channel
and as a purported example of what isn't
defamation he says Indians have poopoo
in the brains still not defamation
PewDiePie actually nails the issue with
that last lyric it's still not
defamation or does he what counts as
defamation well first let's talk about
defamation under US law defamation is
the communication of a false statement
that harms a person or organization's
reputation like the United States
India's legal system is based on English
common law but America India and the UK
approach defamation in completely
different ways the law of defamation is
concerned with stopping publication of
statements that in your persons
reputation this law comes from the
common law of England where Alfred the
great once announced that public slander
was to be compensated with no lighter
penalty than the cutting off of the
slanderers tongue although we aren't
cutting out anyone's tongue for
defamation these days there are now
civil penalties for defamation in the
United States some legal commentators
have noted that all American freedoms
begin with freedom of speech and over
the years American law has developed a
doctrine of defamation that tries to
balance harm to someone's reputation
with the anti censorship tradition of
the First Amendment so let's do a quick
review of how to prove defamation in
America there are two kinds of
defamation historically slanders
defamation by spoken word alone whereas
libels defamation by written word video
or song but in the modern context there
isn't much differentiation it's
basically all defamation a communication
may be considered defamatory if it quote
tends to so harmed the reputation of
another as to lower him in the
estimation of the community or to deter
third persons from associating with him
to prove defamation the defendant must
show three things the defendant
knowingly or negligently made a false
and defamatory statement of verifiable
fact concerning the plaintiff the
defendant made an unprivileged
publication to a third party and the
publisher acted at least negligently in
publishing the communication the
statement must be of course untrue and
harmful to one's reputation the
defendant can
defend him or herself by claiming that
the statements are literally true but
the burden of proof is on the person who
says the statements are defamatory to
show that the statements are actually
false American law has an even higher
standard when the plaintiff is a public
figure when the statements involve a
public figure it doesn't matter if they
happen to be false in those cases a
plaintiff must also show that whoever
made the statement did so with what's
called actual malice by choosing the
standard American law has chosen to tip
the balance in favor of free speech
India on the other hand tips the balance
in favor of protecting the person or
entity's reputation mind you I am NOT an
Indian lawyer this is merely my
understanding based on my research as an
outsider looking in so take my
statements with a grain of salt so let's
talk about defamation under Indian law
the Indian Constitution protects freedom
of speech under article 19 to that
Constitution however defamation is an
exception to the general protections of
free speech India makes a person's
reputation as a key aspect of the right
to life which is also guaranteed under
the Indian Constitution
India's definition of defamation is the
quote publication of a statement which
reflects on a person's reputation and
tends to lower him or her in the
estimation of right-thinking members of
society generally or tends to make them
shun or avoid him or her in India
defamation can be both a civil and
criminal cause of action India is
actually one of the few countries that
makes defamation a criminal offence
India's Penal Code criminalizes any
speech the quote promotes emnity between
different groups on grounds of religion
race place of birth resident and
language Indian Penal Code section 499
makes defamation a crime punishable by
up to two years in prison it defines
defamation as a statement concerning any
person intending to harm or knowing or
having reason to believe that his
statement will harm the person's
reputation the existence of criminal
penalties for defamatory speech
contributes to an overall environment
that is unbalanced chilling to free
speech if you fear potential jail after
all you're going to think twice about
what you publish while there are several
exceptions to section 499 truth is not
always one of those exceptions and the
civil claim in India
is similar truth is a defense only if
the statement was made for the public
good
if the statement was true but was
intended to hurt someone's reputation
then under Indian law defamation still
applies defamation in India includes
statements made against corporations
people and even the deceased as well
defamation can include things which are
just jokes the Indian law states that an
imputation in the form of an alternative
or expressed ironically may amount to
defamation so looking at pewdiepie is
case beautifies defense that his videos
are just jokes would work pretty well in
the u.s. satire and parody are good
defenses to defamation satire can be a
sharp political critique and such
commentary is well within speech rights
in the u.s. parody makes light of a
situation and although it's not as
sharply critical satire parody is also a
valid defense to charges of defamation
when it comes to parody as long as the
false statement is so over the top and
ridiculous that no one would take it
seriously then that defense is likely to
succeed and it's also what happened in
the infamous case of Jerry Falwell vs.
hustler magazine when hustler magazine
published a parody account of Jerry
Falwell 'he's first sexual encounter
Falwell sued the magazine for defamation
hustler and its owner Larry Flynt
prevailed because no reasonable person
would have considered the humerus and
parodic article to be a true account of
fall wells private life so the upshot of
all of this is that the same YouTube
video that could be considered
defamatory in India is almost certainly
except a little free speech in the
United States although the Indian High
Court ruled that YouTube had to block
cutie-pies videos in India it's a fairly
good bet that PewDiePie is going to win
this war and more often than not free
speech rights are probably going to
prevail and you will still be able to
watch PewDiePie's parodies and satire
for a long time to come but you can also
bet that this probably won't be the last
time there's litigation between t-series
and pewdiepie the top two YouTube
channels in the entire world shift blame
whatever you could do okay never take
responsibility if you take
responsibility and that's omitting that
you're wrong and doing that
possible if you want to learn how to
make your own possibly defamatory songs
and get sued in India you'll first need
to learn how to mix and produce your own
songs to do that I would recommend young
guru Skillshare course learn how to mix
music with DJ young guru he covers
everything you could possibly want to
know about making your own music
including organizing the mix tweaking
the levels and adding effects he can't
keep you from getting sued in the High
Court of India but he can help to make
sure your diss track sounds awesome
Skillshare is an online learning
community that has over 25,000 classes
on everything like lifestyle design and
technology
the first 500 legal eagles will get two
free months of Skillshare when you click
on the link below plus it really helps
out this channel the free premium
membership gives you unlimited access to
must know topics so you can improve your
skills and learn new things so click on
the link below get two free months of
skills share and start learning to think
like a lawyer today it could even help
you become internet famous do you agree
with my analysis do you think the US
courts have the right conception of
defamation or do you think that the more
expansive Indian version gets it right
leave your objections down below in the
comments and check out my other real law
reviews over here where I will see you
in court